greetings anime fans i've been looking
at the feedback from a previous video
and it looks like i learned a little
something you guys can't get enough of
anime final fights the 500k view says
something about it so i'm here to
deliver more without further ado here
are my next favorite final fights in
anime after going through some of the
most epic final fights in anime before
what else does the medium have in store
let's find out let's start with shiro vs
gilgamesh
if you were to rank my favorite fate
series battles this must be near the top
for me unlimited blade works is the
perfect sequel to fate zero in terms of
narrative and while each route has its
pros i feel that this is the route that
leads to the most natural conclusion of
the story that started in zero after all
this is the route where shiro comes to
understand his ideals and uses his
knowledge to cleanly beat the king of
heroes it's an underdog battle which
doesn't even feel like one thanks to
shiro perfectly countering gilgamesh's
abilities he made our hero look like a
badass worth a million bucks with how he
gets under gilgamesh's skin it's a
complete trouncing of gilgamesh that
feels deserved and well-earned it also
has my favorite remix of the emiya theme
so that's something as well
let's move on to an underrated fight
shinichi versus goto
when i first watched parasite i already
knew that it's not your ordinary anime i
was fully dazzled by the themes and the
narrative that the show carried and i
especially enjoyed the dynamic between
shinichi and migi i'd be lying if i said
that i didn't get emotional when
shinichi lost migi towards the end but
that makes the triumph in the final
battle against gotoh so special left
without his trusted buddy for once
chinichi had to go deep into his bag of
tricks to fend off this ultimate
parasite the reunion was emotional but
the finishing blow well that felt even
more satisfying technically speaking
parasite's final conflict is against
someone else in a brilliant thematic
twist however in terms of boss fights
this is it and it's one of the best
anime final fights that we have
[Music]
next i put kira versus josuke on the
list
how can we have a final fight video
without a mention of jojo especially
this epic showdown that we have here
just gate finally gets his hands on gira
after so long and their fated showdown
left everyone wanting more it's got a
lot of stakes riding on it this one it
has the usual jojo goodness of wacky out
of this world abilities for a show where
you'd expect a lot of craziness to
happen jojo does have its share of well
animated and hype inducing instances of
cqc this is just one of many examples of
sakuga in the series but i feel that
this moment is the best embodiment of it
manga readers have commented on how the
fight could have been handled better but
i think in the grand scheme of things
it's fine anime owners love this
showdown and it's a great way to wrap up
the saga
the same can be said of castlevania as a
series but this last fight pretty much
gives the series a send-off to remember
honestly i'm as much as a gamer as i am
an anime fan and this battle just gives
that big boss vibe it manages to
recapture the thrill of playing a game
and coming face to face with the
ultimate enemy those godlike beings that
you so often see in jrpgs trevor shows
no fear as he faces death himself in
this epic finale and i've got to give a
lot of props to the banter it's not too
often you'd see trash talking this
badass do you it's got some cool action
and a wild ending so make sure to stay
tuned with some amazing animation and
art i was more hyped than ever watching
this fight it felt so good rekindling
the fire that i had for video games back
in my childhood
spike versus vicious from cowboy bebop
is a banger that i failed to include the
last time around rewatching it i
concluded that it's not just my
nostalgia goggles working the fight's
legitimately what you'd love and expect
from a setting like cowboy bebop this is
one of those high-stakes frantic paced
final battles built for hollywood
thrillers and cowboy bebop is one of the
anime fights like this are made for
shootouts sword fights hand-to-hand
combat this fight has got it all this
battle caps off an epic journey with one
of the most gut-wrenching endings you
can have this one's a keeper and if you
need something to convince your
non-anime fan friends what anime can be
like and you can definitely show them
this fight
let's move on with another classic anime
now shall we yomi versus yusuke is one
of the battles that stuck with me
the yomi fight is something that i find
memorable because of a simple fact
yusuke loses where else do you see that
in shonen anime back when i was much
younger and watching yuyu hakusho i
didn't think that it was possible for
the protagonist to lose a high stakes
final battle but he did and having it
happen relatively early in the
tournament it completely blew my mind
away yuyu hakusho continues its string
of breathtaking tournament arc with the
three kings arc you get your fair share
of magical attacks but i think that the
emotional weight of the clash is what
sold me on it despite finding a new
power like most protagonists do use gate
still doesn't have what it takes to beat
yomi leaving more than a few fans
disappointed at least he didn't go down
without putting on an entertaining show
though did he it all worked out in the
end and you can't tell me that this
fight doesn't have its share of
emotional moments that had us hooked for
minutes on end
i'm not sure how hot of a take this is
but i feel that dragon ball z should
have ended in the cell saga it's the
most organic ending for the series with
a real touching passing of the torch
moment from goku to gohan but you know
executive meddling and money means that
the show must go on a lot of people talk
about it like it's a bad thing which at
times it really is however without said
executive meddling we would have gotten
some awesome moments to be fondly
remembered like a lot of the nifty
fights in dragon ball super a decade ago
have you wondered what dragon ball would
look like with modern colors and
technology super's got you covered that
or this final battle against kid buu by
all means i don't think it's the best
dragon ball z fight out there but it's
got all you want in a finale an
over-the-top battle full of run-ins and
everyone contributing in their own ways
to finally bringing down kid buu i just
love these all your powers combined
final attacks that they often do in
anime and the super spirit bomb is one
of my first encounters with the trope
[Music]
let's continue with the oldie but goody
train with vash versus knives
brother battles are cool because often
they already carry that emotional weight
required for us to care about the fight
more than that there's just something
appealing about good old one-on-one
shootouts trigun's final battle does
just that and leaves me very satisfied
the fight does an excellent job of
giving us a sense of tension with each
move and the action has little dead air
as you can feel each brother's will to
defeat the other it also has that crazy
quick draw scene that culminates in a
breathtaking sequence well for its time
where vash steals victory from the jaws
of defeat the fight's just so smooth and
fluid for its time as well and when i
don't think it's aged too well it was
spectacular when i first saw it
speaking of brother battles how about a
look at hyakimaru vs tahomaru
for me much of donaro's appeal is the
chase besides the budding relationship
with doraro the adventure of following
hikimaru in his quest to get his body
parts one by one is the thing that
thoroughly immersed me in the series
that's why this final battle feels like
such a good payoff yakimaru vs tahomaru
is every bit as intense as you'd expect
from the climactic battle of an
action-adventure story and it delivered
the fight choreography is top notch and
the momentum shifts throughout the
battle kept me on the edge eagerly
awaiting for the next phase of the
battle besides this great fight i also
like the message and the catharsis
factor in this fight yakimaru deciding
to spare his brother is such a strong
moment considering what happened
beforehand it's a very powerful ending
to a long and treacherous journey and it
made every step on the way worth it
[Music]
so which is your favorite fight amongst
these i want to know your thoughts so
make sure to check out the comments and
do a bit of sharing it helps youtube
algorithm and i'd love to talk to you
guys about your favorite final fights
too if you're interested you can also
check out our channel memberships for
perks also don't forget to drop by
patreon your support would really be
appreciated that does it for today thank
you for watching and hope to see you
again
[Music]